hey guys do you get a lot of headaches i
mean we all get headaches now and then
right they're not fun but you know what
causes your headaches in the first place
this is actually a lot more important
than you think because well just think
about it
if you know what causes your headaches
to occur in the first place then you'll
also know how to prevent them now you
might get a headache because of physical
factors like an injury or bad body
posture or it might be medical like a
cold fever or allergies you might also
experience a migraine or headaches
because of high blood pressure genetics
is another factor especially when it
comes to migraines or it might also be
because of environmental factors like
the weather secondhand smoking allergens
certain foods pollution
lighting and even strong smells in your
house like chemicals or perfumes
you might also get headaches because of
an unhealthy lifestyle and emotional
factors like stress depression anxiety
alcohol skipping meals and changes in
sleep atoms now let me just get into
this a little bit more you get different
types of headaches like a tension type
headache a migraine a cluster headache
thunderclap headache and a headache from
overusing medication
and then there are also other headaches
like the allergy or sinus headache the
caffeine headache menstrual migraines
exertion headaches spinal headaches
post-traumatic headaches hypertension
headaches amen
there's a lot more there's actually
around 150 types of headaches at this
care moment i feel like people just make
up names as we go along
but some of them are very serious so let
me just warn you if you experience any
of the following symptoms you need to go
to the hospital or to a doctor as soon
as possible visual loss vomiting stiff
neck rash slurred speech paralysis in
some part of your body confusion
or a fever of over 38 degrees or 100
fahrenheit don't play around with your
health
it's
look you only have one life right you
don't want to waste it and there are
thousands of people that have regret
because they didn't act sooner now the
most basic headache that you will
probably get is the tension type
headache you'll probably feel tension
around your forehead on both sides of
your head and the pain slowly but surely
gets worse and it can spread to or from
your neck but the best thing about these
headaches is well they don't really last
that long just a few hours or a few days
in some cases
so
how do you get them how can you prevent
them and how can you get rid of them
well just before i tell you before i
forget if you like my channel if you
like this video so far please remember
to subscribe if you haven't done so
already click the notification bell here
as well so you'll be notified whenever i
upload a new video i really love the
support now we mostly get these
headaches because of an unhealthy
lifestyle stress not getting enough
sleep bad diet dehydration poor posture
and keeping your head in the wrong
position for two long periods
like working on your laptop looking too
far down or up so how do you treat your
headaches or how do you prevent them
well it's easy just start living a
healthy lifestyle eat healthy sleep
seven to eight hours a day drink seven
to eight glasses of water per day and if
you experience stress talk to someone
that can really help you out and if you
want to get rid of a headache fast just
use medicine like aspirin in south
africa we have desperate man
it's great i love it it always works for
me that is
but if it doesn't go away if you want
something stronger go and see your
doctor they might propose keto rolac or
in the methicon and then if you get
headaches just because of allergies then
you can just get over the counter
medicine like antihistamine i use
allergens here in south africa and it
works great
now when it comes to migraines well
there's no cure for this because it's in
your dna
so there might be some treatments for it
you can go and see your doctor
and if you have any other extreme
headaches as well then yes you need to
go and see your doctor as well except if
it comes to
hangovers
that's just your own fault this is just
basically a punishment for getting drunk
you chose to drink so then you got to
live with the consequences and i used to
drink a lot before i became a christian
i was not always a nice person as well
and if you want to know why i changed my
life why i became a reborn christian
well i didn't really change my life god
changed my life made me a new creation a
better person if you want to know the
truth it's going to be a very
interesting video and i've shared my
testimony on my other channel you can
watch that video here and i'll see you
there and before you go always remember
life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys